[Music]
let's
bring in professor gianta batacharya
he's an epidemiologist and public health
expert at the university of stanford in
california
his research focuses on the health of
vulnerable populations
he co-authored the great barrington
declaration along with oxford's
sunitra gupta who we had on the show
just a few weeks ago
it's advocating a different way to deal
with the pandemic it's not
keen on lockdowns he has a new article
published online
on the spectator website today uh
professor welcome
to spectator tv uh it seems
that governments cannot resist lockdowns
that mr
macron set his face against one but he's
doing it
mr johnson set his face against one we
expect him to do it too
why do you think that is well it's it's
really tempting
because you think that we can control
the spread of the virus with this
general lockdown
but lockdowns have proven not to be very
effective
in controlling the spread i mean uk had
a lockdown
general lockdown earlier this year and
yet the virus continued to spread
argentina has had a lockdown yet the
virus continued to spread but
we've seen sort of the failure of
lockdowns everywhere what's what we need
are new ideas for
containing the damage of the virus
rather than to try to contain the
general spread of the virus
which has proved to be a poor strategy
one
reason for the original lockdown was the
capacity of our health systems would
they be overwhelmed let's try
and spread it out a bit so they weren't
that would still seem to be a problem
though president macron said last night
that there would soon be 9
000 covert patients needing intensive
care
in france that it was a danger of
swamping the system that is a reason for
a lockdown is it not
it might be a better approach would be
to expand
capacity locally when it's necessary
right so build field hospitals and other
other facilities that can
address the overflow should be there i
mean i think it's very important to note
that
uh the the the cues for other services
get delayed extensively as a result of
these kinds of uh these sort of uh
attempts to reduce this the the pressure
on hospital assistance and anticipation
in many many parts of the country for
instance the united states during the
general lockdown in
in march and april uh the hospitals ran
empty and people who had needed cancer
services or or
other services basically delayed care i
think the similar things have happened
in the uk
and france basically everywhere where
our locker has happened there are a few
concentrated places where
at risk of being overrun with kobe cases
and most of the rest of the country
end up uh hospitals empty that don't
serve patients that that die from other
causes
so i think a better approach is a is a
is to have an expansion of capacity
locally
use use methods to move patients uh to
places where there's less
uh you know less pressure those are
smarter approaches
but can you expand intensive care
quickly
the technology is complicated the
training can take years and years can
you really just
ramp it up in response to horizon cases
well i mean
the question is like how much do you
need of it right so i think i think the
answer is yes i mean i think we've seen
uh in many places uh the the uh
expertise in managing patients has grown
substantially uh
you can use paid physicians who are uh
they may not be always in intensive care
but that but they have some training
there's a lot of creative ways to
address
this kind of constraint
you talk about focused protection
instead of a lockdown the lockdown
you think is a bit of a sledgehammer
focused protection
what do you mean by that so it's very
it's very simple
in one sense we know that the virus is
much more deadly for
older people and people with a few
chronic conditions
we should do everything we possibly can
to help them so for instance
nursing homes are absolutely the the
deadliest places to be
when you don't have focus protection we
should use our testing resources
and other ingenuity to protect people
living in care homes
uh because that's where the the virus
ends up killing
um on the other hand on the other hand
like with the lockdown we ask older
workers
who are potentially vulnerable to the
disease to go back into the workforce
because they're essential and expose
themselves to the virus the lockdown
doesn't protect them um
so i think use use our welfare systems
uh and you know disability accommodation
laws so that we
can provide support for those workers so
they don't have to go
you know get be exposed to the virus uh
the lockdown actually creates
multi-generational homes
right young adults move back in with
older parents exposing the parents uh
because the economic harm from the
lockdown
um the universities sometimes get closed
uh so you you end up actually creating
more depth than you would expect
as a result of the lockdown you need
much more creative ways of dealing with
this
same time younger populations the harm
from covid is less
than the harm from the lockdowns
themselves the psychological harm the
physical harm
and other harms on net we're asking uh
with the general lockdown for a younger
population to
essentially accept this harm even though
it hasn't actually helped suppress the
diamonds from the virus
focus protection is let's take advantage
of what we know about the virus
and design an intelligence strategy as
opposed to a sledgehammer to deal with
it
so if we focus protection on the older
the more vulnerable those with
underlying conditions that could make
them
susceptible to covert how would we do
that if we
we wouldn't want young people to visit
the older people or younger families or
even their
grown-up kids to visit them who looks
after them
if they their family can't go and see
them
no andrew that's a really important
question and i think um for instance we
can use these new rapid tests so if
you're
going to go visit your uh your uh parent
in a nursing home you take a rapid test
if you're negative then you can you go
if you're positive now this would be a
personal decision so if it's
your older parent is feeling lonely uh
you have to
make a quick decision about what to
whether to go you have to balance that
against the potential harm from
spreading covet each person is would be
in a better position than in a general
a dictat that says oh no no you can't go
uh you have to stay within two miles
like the lockdown in
in victoria for instance australia was
you couldn't even travel very far
outside of your home
um i mean these kinds of things are much
more isolating
versus a focused protection approach
which allows each person to make
decisions based on accurate information
um and resources that are poured into
helping make them make those decisions
as a
i mean i think a blunderbuss approach as
we've seen has not
worked and causes enormous harm
in other things other than coving we
should be thinking about public health
from a more holistic point of view
and i think we'll do better with both
covet and non-cove
sort of sources of harm from public
health the goal should be public
flourishing not a human flourishing not
simply
infection control the scientific
community seems to be pretty divided on
this you had plenty of people
signing your declaration distinguished
scientists doing so
yet anthony fauci in the united states
he called it quote total nonsense
and the wh so the world health
organization said
it's scientifically and ethically
problematic
it's hard for the rest of us when the
top experts can't agree
i mean it's unfortunately but that's the
case that there are a lot of
disagreement in the scientific community
over this
i'd ask you to look at the record of
lockdowns the the record of the
lockdowns in the united states has been
terrible we've had 220 000 deaths
many of which were under were avoidable
and almost 100
000 excess deaths above and beyond that
from non-coveted sources
that which will continue to grow in the
future as as the harm from
skipping cancer treatments and other
other kinds of things that that got lost
the psychological harm of people with uh
one in four young adults seriously
considering suicide just this past june
in the united states
i don't think that's uncommon i think
that's typical of the rest of the world
lockdowns are not a way for people to
live and they will have enormous harm in
coming years i think
uh that assessment will start to move in
our direction very very soon as we start
to see
the mounting harms from the lockdown i
thought that these excess death figures
you mentioned
uh professor in the united states i
thought were interesting
so the cdc says 300 000 excess deaths
over what you'd normally expect on the
five-year average
up 200 000 they had related to covert
but a hundred thousand not related to
covert
but in some way probably related to
covert in the sense that
you couldn't get the cancer treatment
you couldn't be treated for depression
or stress and so on is that correct
yeah but i mean i wouldn't call it covet
i would call that lockdown that's those
are lock down deaths is what those are
you can contrast that with sweden six
thousand cobot does nothing on the order
six thousand sweeps
if i'm if i have to think about correct
uh where only two thousand
on the order of two thousand excess
deaths fewer excess deaths than
coven deaths in sweden today um they've
minimized the non-excess deaths the
non-coveted deaths
the lockdown deaths and actually i think
save lives as a consequence
i think we should be thinking in that
way we shouldn't just be looking at
covert cases and say okay we failed or
succeeded we should be thinking about
public health generally and decide if we
fail to succeed
professor is it uh your fear
that we've been in one lock down with
him we came out
we by we i mean europe parts of the
united states too we're going into
another lockdown
that it's it's a kind of hokey cokey
lockdown we're doing it
in out in out is that the danger
of the current consensus that is exactly
the danger andrew and i think that that
is where we're headed if we keep
if we don't look for alternatives uh you
know i know france is locked down
as fraser said uh i think germany is
considered or maybe maybe they've
already decided
i think this sort of policy myopia is a
mistake
there are better alternatives available
alternatives that actually have
succeeded
uh not it's not just theoretical
alternatives uh and we should adopt
those because it would
it would uh it would result in both
better covet outcomes and non-coded
outcomes the lockdowns don't protect the
vulnerable
we've seen that uh and if we adopt
another lockdown again again the
vulnerable will be
will be exposed the controlling
community spread
broadly is not the only way of managing
the damage from this epidemic
um we have to think more creatively than
we have professor
gianta bhattacharya from the university
of stanford in california i know it's
early
where you are so we're particularly
grateful that you joined us today on
spectator tv thank you very much
[Music]
you